il veut écouter ma maquette c'est
quelqu'un qui qui fait un travail en or
et et moi il va écouter mon travail à
moi et je le connais pas personnellement
tu vois à cette à cette période là je
connais son travail et c'est là que je
me dis en fait il va reconnaître
peut-être mon travail et il va me donner
des conseils et c'était surtout ça que
je voulais parce qu'à 15 ans tu peux pas
te tu peux pas te promettre grande
animatrice radio et cetera d'accord et
ma sœur me dit bon écoute allez c'est
bon vas-y je t'emmène je t'emmène je
vais je vais demander à à donc à son
copain et cetera et il décide de
m'emmener donc on y va le lendemain
d'accord bon et donc là bon donc la tar
J et qu'est-ce qui se passe alors là-bas
donc au départ et je tiens à le
préciser je lui ai dit écoute je suis
pas sûr de venir et il me dit ah mais
toi en fait tu ne peux jamais bouger
point d'exclamation point d'exclamation
point d'exclamation il y avait trois
points d'exclamation tu ne peux jamais
bouger
euh de ce fait j'ai répondu que si je
pouvais bouger et que je trouverais des
solutions donc je l'ai trouvé et c'est
là qu'il m'a donné rendez-vous à son
hôtel précis telle heure telle date
enfin bref tout ça j'y suis allée donc
avec mon beau-frère ma
sœur on a bu un
verre et et et à ce moment-là à un
moment donné dans parce que mon frère il
y avait mon frère moi ma sœur lui et à
ce moment-là en fait il s'est on a bu et
cetera et il s'est dit bon bah on va
aller moi il faut que j'aille me
préparer Julie vient avec moi écouter ma
me faire écouter ta maquette on monte
dans la
chambre ton beaufrère ta ta sœur vont
aller vont aller au casino parce qu'il y
avait un casino dans l'haôuteil vont
aller au casino et puis et puis on verra
après donc moi je décide de monter avec
avec lui donc donc donc encore une fois
la présempption d'innocence est
là je l'ai fait je l'ai suivi et
euh et ma sœur était un petit peu contre
elle sentait le je sais je sais pas
pourquoi elle elle le sentait pas mais
j'y suis allée quand même et c'est à ce
moment-là que que que s'est passé que ce
sont passés les
fait les fait que voilà tu dis que les
fait que tu as déjà expliqué euh voilà
les faits que j'ai déjà expliqué qui
pour moi et qui pour moi ont été euh ont
été très très difficiles à entendre
parce que lui je je je le comprends et
pour sa compagne aussi je comprends que
ça ce soit très difficile et je le redis
encore je l'aurais dit encore
aujourd'hui il y a la présemption
d'innocence et chacun se fait son avis
propre et personnel mais moi à à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui j'ai je suis
complètement anéanti coup mais c'était
c'était il y a c'était il y a 10 ans
cette affaire c'était il y a 10 ans
ouais et tu l'as revu après je l'ai revu
ouais combi combien combien de jours
combien de semaines après tu l'as revu
plusieurs fois ou je l'ai revu plusieurs
fois j'ai tu allais encore à ces
émissions tu allais encore dans le
public j'allais encore à ces émissions
j'allais encore au public mais
d'ailleurs j'étais venu vous voir avec
j'ai d'ailleurs des photos mais mais en
fait j'allais faire plein d'émissions
radio moi j'étais j'étais passionnée de
ça mais mais après ça parce qu'il je te
dis les gens se posent question se
disent pourquoi tu as continué à aller
dans le public pourquoi tu as continué à
le voir je me suis persuadé que ce qui
était arrivé en fait ce n'était pas ce
n'était pas réel ce qui était arrivé
c'était pas dramatique parce que ça a
duré peut-être je dirais une minute
avant que les appels de ma sœur
retentisse des dizaines de fois et je me
suis dit ça tout ça c'est pas IR réel
tout ça c'est pas réel mais donc il faut
que tu te persuade que en fait tout ça
c'est Julie pourquoi 10 ans
après tu t'es dit je vais je vais
témoigner et je vais je vais parler de
l'affaire tout ça parce que comme tu le
sais puisquon sa'est on s'est eu au
téléphone bien avant et il y a eu un
tweet de de de de c'est ça exactement
qui a demandé à ce qu'on ce qu'on ce
qu'on parle de nos rencontres de
célébrité mais pas en terme méchant bien
sûr c'était pas c'était pas en terme
méchant et moi je me suis dit mais mais
cet hommelà il fait du mal et il fait
vraiment du mal et j'ai eu des
témoignages de de de femmes il y a 25
ans il y a 25 ans de ça et et et cela je
suis capable de regarder Gill Verdes
dans les yeux parce
que il a été capable de et ça je je veux
bien être sur et je veux bien le dire tu
as pu prendre la défense de cohé tu as
pe prenner la défense de C et tu as le
droit de parler hein c'est c'est c'est
pas c'est pas contre toi honnêtement
parce que on a le droit de donner la
parole de Cé comme on a le droit de
donner ma parole et la présomption
d'innocence et je voudis dire il y a
beaucoup de gens qui nous disent
pourquoi Julie est là ce soir parce que
même par rapport à l'arcom sachezle on a
donné la version de Cé et la chaîne m'a
dit il faut absolument avoir Julie la
version de elle a le droit relat la
version de
l' exctement non mais mais moi mais moi
je vous donne la parole à tous parce que
moi je suis je je la présempption
d'innocence est là chacun a le droit
d'avoir son avis à partir du moment où
on laisse la justice faire oui c'est la
justice quia qui que ce soit déjà là il
y a déjà un procès médiatique déjà Julie
puis qu'il a été même il il a d'énergie
voilà c'est ça donc là déjà c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui le procès médiatique va
plus vite que la justice oui mais le
procès médiatique voilà je leur dis
encore une fois voilà je me suis
peut-être un peu emballé moi aussi à
dire bon ben je vais parler en mon nom
mais c'était pour recueillir des
témoignages tu vois parce que moi toute
seule on m'aurait jamais on m'aurait
jamais pris au sérieux est-ce que vous
regrettez aujourd'huiou est-ce que vous
sentez mieux je me sens mieux parce que
il a détruit ma famille il m'a détruit
moi aussi et là j'arrive à renouer des
liens avec ma famille en ayant dit la
vérité mais justement Julie parce qu'on
me dit que même encore l'an dernier vous
vous vous l'avez vu vous avez été à ces
émissions l'an dernier j'ai pas été à
ces émissions non c'est quand la
dernière fois que vous êtes allé la
dernière fois c'était bien avant le
covid donc ça devait être en 2018 tu
vois et quand est-ce que vous avez une
prise de conscience en vous
disant
voilà quand la prise de conscience que
j'ai eu c'est à partir du moment où j'ai
où j'ai où j'ai rencontré quelqu'un où
j'ai été en couple d'accord et et et la
fille enfin parce qu'il avait un il
avait une
fillefin cet Hommel oui et elle avait 8
ans et elle avait vu mes photos sur
facebook enfin elle avait regardé mon
profil facebook tout ça grâce à mon
téléphone et elle avait dit wou tu
connais cé je veux trop aller le voir
viens on va le voir emmène-moi le voir
emmène-moi le voir et là je me suis dit
à 8 ans la fille elle te demande
ça et elle elle te considère comme sa
belle-mère et elle te considère comme
tout ce qui ce qu'il y a de plus cher au
monde non mais donc j'ai continué à lui
faire croire et en fait moi moi je vous
crois à 200 % je crois et je l'ai dit
hier il faut aller au bout tout ce que
vous avez comme preuve faut aller au
bout parce que si comme vous dites c'est
quelqu'un qui pendant 25 ans a fait des
trucs vous avez dit là il y a des
histoires depuis 25 ans vous il a
massacré votre vie il a massacré votre
famille je vous crois alors si vous a
massacré il faut pas laisser faut pas
laisser faire ça et d'un autre côté on
on m'envoie des des trucs et des images
et des photos et on me dit que là par
exemple il il y a pas longtemps Cyril
dit il y a 10 ans et il y a un an vous
êtes venu à son émission télé moi j'en
reviens juste à votre facebook actuel
votre facebook de maintenant il y a des
photos de partout avec koe et vous êtes
en fond d'écran avec koe pourquoi rester
en fond d'écran avec un mec qui a
massacré votre vie c'est mon avis
personnel je parce que moi je suis un
peu con si quelqu'un a massacré ma vie
je suis pas en fond d'écran sur Facebook
avec lui je le sors de ma vie et
j'essaie de le trîner devant les
tribunaux et j'essaie de faire prouver
qu'il a fait quelque chose de mal mais
il est pas en Facebook en fond d'écran
répondu il est il est pas en fond
d'écran sur Facebook alors attention
j'ai deux Facebook ah je compte je
précise je précise à le dire j'ai perdu
un mot de passe j'ai recréé un autre
compte donc il y a un compte où je sais
pas il est peut-être encore avec avec
lui en fond d'écran mais maintenant à
l'heure actuelle mon fond d'écran c'est
ma grand-mère faut l'enlever faut
l'enlever c'est ma grand-mère mais j'ai
plus le mot de passe pour l'enlever mais
c'est ma grand-mère actuellement qui est
en sur mon vrai compte Facebook c'est ma
grand-mère Julie il y a beaucoup de gens
aussi je te dis est-ce que je te dis
toutes les questions que les gens se
posent il y a beaucoup de gens aussi qui
disent les conversations que tu as mis
sur les réseaux on voit que cé vraiment
enchaîne les questions seul et tu ne lui
réponds jamais euh il y a beaucoup de
gens qui s'étonnent de ça qu'est-ce que
tu réponds de ça qu'est-ce que je
réponds non est-ce que parce que je te
dis voilà je te dis les questions qui
reviennent comme
voilà supprimer les réponses supprimer
vos réponses pour les laisser que c'est
c'est moi lui non absolument pas non
d'accord non mais c'est voilà c'est'é
important que tu tu dis parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de gens qui gens qui dis qu'
parlent tout seul il a parlé tout seul
de de 16h jusqu'à 23h en fait il a parlé
de 16h jusqu'à 23h parce que à ce moment
sans réponse sans réponse il y a pas de
conversation en fait en fait il y avait
pas de conversation à ce moment-là en
fait où on s'est dit euh parce que il
est arrivé à plusieurs reprises où où où
on est échangé et depuis de de 2000 de
2014 à aujourd'hui on se on se parle et
euh jusqu'au 8 août parce que notre
dernière conversation s'est arrêtée au 8
août comme Gill Verdes pourrait
peut-être le confirmer
oui oui j'ai les mêmes informations sur
le 8 août le 8 août et ben cet été oui
ou ouais c'est ça cet été donc donc non
en fait il y avait pas de il y avait pas
d'autres conversation il a continué à
faire à faire cela tu aimerais qu'il se
passe quoi maintenant Julie alors je ce
qui se passe je je je peux pas lui je
peux pas lui souhaiter de j'arriverai
pas à souhaiter de mal à qui que ce soit
d'accord parce que moi le mal je l'ai
vécu et je je n'arriverai pas à
souhaiter de mal à qui que ce soit je
travaille dans le domaine de la santé
maintenant moi le il y a des gens qui
qui vivent pire que pire que pire que la
misère du monde et j'arriverais pas tu
as été dégoûté du métier j'ai été
dégoûteré du métier et tu fais quoi
aujourd'hui Julie je suis secrétaire
médical j'aide les gens ça se passe bien
ça se passe très bien bah merci d'être
venu nous voir et d'avoir donné ta
version ce soir c'éta important pour
nous en direct merci beaucoup merci et
merci d'avoir d'être intervenu merci à
tous tout de suite